[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
your fantasy
fire drill i am matt camp back with you
for another season here at br gridiron
and we're gonna get you ready for the
2021 fantasy football season
and lead you to yet another championship
that's what we do here we'll be taking
your questions you've been submitting
them keep them going in the br app
because i'll be talking rookies and
injuries and so much more not only today
on this thursday but for the next three
thursdays at 1pm eastern as we go
through the preseason get you ready
keeper questions dynasty questions
trades will monitor everything going
down leading in to week one of the
regular season the cowboys and the
defending world champion tampa bay
buccaneers but
before we get to all of that as you are
preparing your draft boards your
rankings what your teams may look like
you may want to have some rookies on
that team you should never shy away from
rookies in fantasy football because
opportunity knocks for some of these
players and they can be immediate
contributors so what i want to do is
talk about the rookies that i have
in my top 100 rankings we'll reveal my
running back rank later on top five
there some faces in some new places but
let's start with the rookies that i like
right now in my top 100 rankings half
point ppr are going to start with naje
harris the first round draft pick of the
pittsburgh steelers and remember he's
coming to a steeler team that wants to
get back to running the football ben
rossberger has been in the league since
2004. yes it's a nice wide receiver
group there's no doubt about that but
when you look at the running backs here
this team has struggled whether it was
benny snell or jalen samuels najee
harris being a first round draft pick to
me tells me he is going to be right
there from day one an important part of
the steeler offense rb 13 for me in my
rankings and 23rd overall let's move
down a little bit here talk about
another running back we'll go down to
jacksonville and talk about travis and
tien now you might be saying what about
what james robinson did last year he was
one of the surprise fantasy championship
players of 2020. he helped me win
there's no doubt about that but travis
entien rb 22 for me 44th overall and at
least early on in the season i think
antiguan's going to be a very important
pass catcher very important part of the
passing game for the jacksonville
jaguars and that could morph into a
bigger role robinson will still have
value but i really like travis santia
we'll talk more about that how about in
cincinnati joe burrow coming back for a
major injury unlike jamar chase aj green
is gone yes they have boyd yes they have
higgins yes they have joe mixon but
chase is a dangerous player as you can
see by the numbers a very very
productive college career he is my wide
receiver 21 and 49th overall so yes i
think he's a wide receiver two on the
low end for fantasy from day one let's
go out west let's go out to the san
francisco 49ers kyle shanahan i'll say
this over and over again
loves your fantasy team always a fantasy
friendly offense and the running back
position if you can ever figure out who
it is has always been productive under
kyle shanahan for the san francisco
49ers rv 24 50th overall i am well aware
that raheem mostar is still there but
everybody else for the most part has
been cleared out of that backfield
questions at the quarterback position
we'll get to that but i really do
believe trey sermon
if
maybe he's not the guy from the jump but
he should have it for the majority of
the season a low end rb2 for me now
one of the biggest rookies who can make
an immediate impact is playing for the
atlanta falcons and that is kyle pitts
julio jones is in tennessee we'll get to
that coming up in a later little bit
kyle pitts is the man for the atlanta
falcons at the tight end position calvin
really is going to be great top five
wide receiver we all know that but to me
kyle pitts is stepping into a situation
where the atlanta falcons don't have a
very good defense they will be throwing
it a lot we'll talk about mike davis in
their backfield you don't always get
very excited about rookie tight ends but
the opportunity is too great for kyle
pitts and i think it's going to be a
very tough player to cover especially
when calvary really is on the field as
well let's go down a little bit though
we'll go out to denver and the back
field here this is an intriguing offense
is it going to jail in 2021 a very fair
question but it also cleared up a little
bit with some moves in the offseason
melvin gordon is still there but now
enters javonte williams rb 27 56 for me
overall so you're looking at him as an
rb3 pretty much to begin the season
somebody in your flexbot i'm not saying
he has to be in your lineup from week
one but i think with the numbers you see
here in college and the opportunity in
denver eventually he should be the guy
there considerment rb3 to open the
season with the arrow pointing up and
finally a team i'm not quite as excited
about and often you want to stay away
from bad teams but there seems to be a
major opportunity here for running back
rookie michael carter of the new york
jets rb 28 for me 57th overall
tevin coleman you know you got p ryan
there for the jets
some injuries at the wide receiver group
corey davis coming over a lot of
questions about this new york jets team
so i'm not going to be super excited
about a running back like this the
receiving numbers are
somewhat encouraging on a team that may
not be that good so he can catch some
passes there but i think michael carter
when you look at that backfield nothing
special there a name to keep an eye on
of the rookies those are the rookies
that have landed in my top 100 these
rankings will adjust throughout the
month of august leading into week one of
the season but you have questions let's
talk about some of your rookie questions
here before we move on to some new faces
and some new places came is who is the
jaguars running back to draft and count
on ntn or robinson here's what i have
i've indiana 22 i have robinson at 32.
as we take a look at this preseason
we'll see how things are shaking out
we'll see uh who's playing with the
first team are they mixing both players
in i happen to think that will happen as
you see the numbers last year james
robinson did a really good job he
contributed in all facets he kind of
came out of nowhere and what did he do
he took advantage of the opportunity
however it did not stop the jaguars from
taking travis in the end eileen his way
it could be more of a split in terms of
touches early on but to me mtn is the
guy to have but
the draft isn't everything anymore
waiver wire is important keep an eye on
both of these players let's move on to
another question here
as not only are a lot of you playing in
your you know regular re-draft leagues
in your dynasty leagues and battle hawk
says in a dynasty league which rookie
running back has the most fantasy upside
i think it's lance but i can see the
reasoning in all five i will say this in
a general thought when it comes to
dynasty leaks you should not really be
thinking more than two or three years
ahead there is so much turnover in the
nfl i mean we're gonna get some new
place in new places look where deandre
hopkins is look where he was same thing
with julio it turns over so quickly but
for trey lance yes fantasy friendly
offense i think in dynasty rankings he
falls inside my top 12. is jimmy
garoppolo going to be the starter for
the entire season is it even going to be
the week one starter these are fair
questions it is a fantasy friendly
offense i'm not saying you have to look
at the niners as a good team but you
know if
trey lance gets out there and the
opportunity is there and i think it will
be there probably by this year at some
point
yes he has a lot of upside and once
again it comes back to kyle shanahan a
fantasy friendly coach another question
here uh dr dankenstein is gage a true
sleeper or is going to siphon any would
be fantasy relative i'm talking about
russell gage for the atlanta falcons who
did a really nice uh job last year for
the falcons remember julio only played
nine games for the falcons last year
here are the numbers of a guy we weren't
really talking much about coming into
the season yes calvarily is the man i
certainly like pitts and i told you
about that and if i didn't give you the
number four uh pitts to me is tight end
five fifty third overall so i obviously
like him a lot but it's a bad defense
this is still a pass first team yes
pitts and obviously calvin are the
biggest benefactors from no more julio
there but calvin averaged 7.6 targets
per game the opportunity will be there
for russell gage i look at him as a wide
receiver three however if pitts or
ridley were to go down well that arrow
points a little bit higher a sleeper but
not a league winning sleeper to me uh
moving on from that one here and let's
get back to the rookies where should i
draft
najee harris
so to me i look at him let's say in the
12-team league at the bottom of the
second round the top of the third let me
give you a wonderful spot for najee
harris if you pick in the first three
spots you end up with a mccaffrey or a
dalvin cook and we'll get to my running
back rankings coming up here or zeke and
you come back around in the second round
and you're looking at the board and
najee harris is there he's my rb13 and a
12 teamer that's the top of the rb2
category so if you open up with a
big time superstar running back if you
get him there and then maybe you team
that up with a dk metcalf and alan
robinson on that turn that's a pretty
darn good start to me so let's say
bottom of the second top of the third
i'm very much in best player available
mode when it comes to running backs wide
receivers and tight ends in the first
four rounds we'll get some more of your
questions coming up a little bit but i
told you we're gonna get to new faces
in new places and let's move on to that
now some major wide receivers moving
around we've mentioned them a couple
times already julio jones this is what
he did last year uh we know he missed
time he's a little bit banged up here
coming over the tennessee titans julio
to me
is a luxury player for the tennessee
type you have aj brown you have arguably
the most dominant and efficient running
back in the league in derrick henry and
you have a great quarterback in the last
couple years in ryan tannehill so julio
to me is better in reality versus
fantasy we'll talk more about him coming
up in a little bit another perennial top
ten even top five wide receiver in the
nfl is deandre hopkins and he has gone
west he is now a member of the cardinals
and look he's played with deshaun watson
that's gone well fruit he's played with
far lesser talented quarterbacks and
he's put up strong numbers now he comes
over to arizona he's my wide receiver
four he's number 13 overall on my board
kyler murray obviously a young
quarterback that you want to have a
piece of and de'andre hopkins makes him
that much more valuable cliff kingsbury
has come from the college of the pro
ranks and has been a fantasy friendly
coach in terms of offense in recent
years aj green has come over you have
rhondell jones who they drafted and you
still have christian kirk there who to
me always felt overrated so deandre
hopkins comes into a very very good
situation and you should feel just as
good about him as you have in previous
years with the houston texas let's move
on to the atlanta falcons we talked
about them a lot it seems like so far
and another change for them is their
backfield and it's mike davis now mike
davis
for those of you out there who had chris
mccaffrey on your rosters and then were
smart enough to grab mike davis mike
davis may have kept you afloat because
not only was he able to be a nice
handcuff for chris mccaffrey he was
better than that he played as an rb1
when mccaffrey was out and now he steps
into an atlanta backfield where he's the
guy there's not much there behind mike
davis nobody of note we know what he did
last year for mccaffrey and you look at
atlanta once again and you say they're
probably not that good so maybe you
worry about the carries a little bit
there if they're playing from behind but
he can catch passes he's proven there uh
rb25 to me 52nd overall i think he'd be
a perfect rb3 but if you have him as
your b2 because you wait on that second
running back spot which i like to do i
think it makes perfect sense he's a very
solid running back and a proven one for
fantasy as we saw last year now let's go
out west
let's talk about matthew stafford so is
this more about matthew stafford's value
on the rise or helping the rams in
general i think it's a little of both
much like kyle shanahan san francisco
you talk about mcvay as a fantasy
friendly coach a guy who knows what he's
doing and a guy who i think we're going
to see
the evidence of even more got a heck of
a lot out of jared goff and he's going
to get a heck of a lot a lot more out of
a much better quarterback in matthew
stafford stafford to me qb12 uh i i
probably will move him up i could see
him creeping into my top ten you have
woods you have cup there
i like everything about this situation
and i think stafford is not somebody you
have to run out there and go get i know
the arrow is pointing up coming over
from detroit to now with the rams a far
better situation i don't think you need
to go draft him too early but if he's
sitting there there's eight or nine
quarterbacks off the board and you're in
that 10 11 12 spot of these different
quarterbacks i'm okay going to get him
because i think the upside is there
we're finally going to see matthew
stafford get the respect that he
deserves some of the questions you may
have about some of these players in new
spots and how it may affect their
fantasy value and julio keeps coming up
b brazil uh basil thoughts on julio i've
decided not to keep him and kept keenan
allen and alvin kamara i will tell you
right now
for 2021 i agree with that maneuver i
probably wouldn't have said that in the
last two or three years but i think it
does make a lot of sense because alan
and camara allen keenan allen and alvin
kamara to me are the clear top pass op
options in their respective offenses
camara where right now we know he's a
proven fantasy superstar but michael
thomas is very much up in the air with
waiting to get his surgery where when
will he return to the new orleans saints
and what is the relationship like with
sean payton and the team camara is going
to rack up the touches by the way on a
lesser extent i do like latavius murray
as well just because the saints are
really not that deep and oh by the way
drew brees is retired so i like camaro
there i have allen at wide receiver 30
uh excuse me wide receiver 11 30th
overall uh camaro to me is a top five
running back but the keynote number is
look this guy i just marked down for 100
catches and i expect that to happen and
i think that will continue uh in that
offense and you like the situation there
with the chargers but julio to me is
more of a question mark he's a luxury
you know i think it's a run first
offense as we know it derek henry they
have aj brown there it's not a bad
situation for julio but he's better in
reality versus fantasy to me wide
receiver 20 believe it or not number 48
overall that's as low as i think anyone
has ever ranked julio jones and that
does seem to be indeed for the consensus
let's talk injuries we brought up a
couple already these are injuries we'll
be monitoring throughout the preseason
here is the biggest name so far that's
being talked about carson wentz it
didn't work out in philadelphia they
move on he comes to india it seems like
a fresh start seems positive then this
foot injury pops up and the talk is well
is he going to get surgery well he does
get surgery and the talk was five to
twelve weeks now chris sports it from
espn in the last couple days reporting
he could be on track for week one that's
a lot of different information there in
a very short period of time
i don't love the indianapolis colts
really as a whole and i will tell you
right now other than jonathan taylor i
don't have anybody inside my top 100
that's an indianapolis colt i think we
need to wait and see i think carson
wentz needed to be in perfect health and
feeling good and i don't know how much
he would have played anyway but you
needed to get everybody in tune and
that's not gonna happen now and even if
he's out there for week number one
it's gonna take some time for all of
that chemistry to develop i know they've
had the off season but it's it's not
giving me the best vibes about the
indianapolis colts let's move south
let's talk about the dallas cowboys and
let's talk about amari cooper with this
foot injury because we know what
happened last year and cd lamb is a
really good player we'll probably talk
more about him coming up you got dak
prescott who i'll just group in here
getting another mri and obviously coming
off a major you know leg injury but now
the shoulder is a concern and jay glazer
said that was a baseball injury so you
got the cooper foot injury you got dak
not at at full strength right now a lot
of questions about these dallas cowboys
and it doesn't have any feeling very
good these are situations we need to
keep a very close eye on because if you
hear any positive reports cowboys put
out that tweet uh i didn't feel good
when i saw that it was trying to they
were trying to say no no there's no dark
cloud or everything is fine it doesn't
seem like everything is fine right now
situations we need to keep monitoring as
we also should for another team in the
nfc east that is the new york giants and
one of their biggest off-season
acquisitions is that man right there
that is kenny gallaudet he came down
with a hamstring injury in the last week
here or so soft tissue injuries like
this you know we've seen gallaudet try
to play through injury before it can
work out and it can also not work out
you know a new team here you got barkley
coming back that all seems good he's
good to go but i hate these kind of
injuries a wide receiver on a new team
with a young quarterback is going to
miss some time now you hope they don't
rush him back let's keep an eye on this
one gallaudet as we know can perform as
a wide receiver one when he's on his
game but this is a new situation this is
a make or break season for daniel jones
i think as everybody knows and kenny
gallaudet was brought in to make a
difference can he do so we're going to
have to now wait and see we'll keep a
close eye on this hamstring injury let's
throw one more in here and this is not a
new injury but it's something that has
affected the fantasy backfield of the
los angeles rams cam maker suffering
that torn achilles he's out for the
season so daryl henderson now becomes a
very intriguing player because when we
saw daryl henderson as the man for the
rams he did a pretty good job can he be
the man for the entire season that's
probably a question for any running back
as we know but i think he's proven that
when given the opportunity
he can take that ball and run with that
and put up some fantasy productions to
me daryl henderson is a top 20 running
back i don't think you should go
overboard when it comes to him but i
think this opens up a major opportunity
and stafford should make that offense
better as a whole let's get some
questions in here as it may relate to
some injured players or some fantasy
rankings barclay or camara pick number
four from hutton ppr here's where i have
them i have camaro five
i have barclay six it's back to back
barkley coming off a torn acl doesn't
seem to be any real concerns about it
you know we could fill up the stat sheet
running the ball catching the ball i
think there will be more scoring
opportunities on a better offense
assuming kenny gallaudet is good to go
but i just feel in a ppr that camara is
going to get far more touches i think
he's going to get more tax opportunities
target opportunities on a team that you
know has a lot of questions right now
but one question the saints don't have
is alvin kamara once again five six it's
pretty close you're not gonna go wrong
either way with those two guys all right
speaking of running backs we'll be
revealing some of my rankings at each
position over the next few weeks we're
gonna do so right now
with the running back position so where
do i have the top five running backs
we're gonna start with christian
mccaffrey yes he missed some time last
year but a lot of these are going to
come down to running backs and great
situations chris mccafferty is clearly
the man and he's a proven man for the
carolina panthers you know he's someone
that you go if he had 100 catches you
wouldn't be surprised that seems a
little ridiculous but
they need him he'll get dump offs he can
run the football he can do it all for
the carolina panthers too much
opportunity there to ignore for chris
mccaffrey he is my rb1 for this season
now i think this is where some questions
come in where do you go from here i i
will say it's very close and it's very
nitpicky to pick between these players
but dalvin cook
dalvin cook is going to come up as
someone you go well but the injuries but
but dalvin cook as we saw last year was
great and i think there's some questions
about kirk cousins and how much the
vikings want to rely on him and yes you
have feeling and we know stefan diggs
has gone i think when diggs was gone
last year i asked i got justin jefferson
and that was huge but cook became that's
much more important this guy's ready to
go to me he could fill up the stat sheet
as well i think when it comes down to
the vikings because it's mike zimmer
even though it's a defensive guy they're
going to rely on the run and if her
cousin's your quarterback i would want
to rely on dalvik cook as well let's
move on number three and it is ezekiel
elliott and we've mentioned you know the
questions about the cowboys and the
injuries there but they're gonna go with
this guy when in doubt they always fall
back on this guy and you know he can do
it all and he's gonna catch the ball and
he's gonna run the ball well and he's
going to get the ball at the goal line
and all of these things for the cowboys
they
if any other questions may arise they
know they have zeke so zeke has the rb3
for me is a pretty easy selection we'll
get into some of these other names and
you may say well where's derrick henry
derrick henry's number four if you said
to me i'm taking derrick henry over
ezekiel elliott or dalvin cook i'm not
gonna give you that much of a fight but
i will point out the numbers that you
see
at
the uh receiving numbers because he's
not going to catch the ball derek henry
has never gotten his fantasy production
from catching the ball any time he does
anything in the passing game it's a
bonus of course he may be the best pure
running back in the entire league and
that goes a long way on a run first team
now they've added julio jones you still
have aj brown some people say well that
opal will open things up even more for
derek henry so if he doesn't even get as
many carries he'll get more out of the
carries that's it yeah he gets he's
powerful he's extremely efficient and
they know they can rely on him if you
want to take him at three or two he
finished third last year that says
plenty a player who was absolutely
better in reality versus fantasy and
that's only because he doesn't catch the
ball and let's be honest the titans
don't need to use them in that spot very
often now number five i mentioned them
already is alvin kamara
michael thomas up in the air alvin
kamara can do everything for the saints
i will say i think latavius murray will
get a few extra carries just to make
sure they don't overwork camara but
kamara is going to get 15 carries he's
going to have plenty of targets
per game that's going to continue
regardless of what happens with michael
thomas and when he comes back and if
they can develop these other players and
figure out whatever they're doing at the
quarterback spot
but camara is gonna do everything that
the saints need just out of necessity i
don't worry about him the injuries last
year we know but look the touchdowns
were there he's someone who also while
not as big as murray will get the
touches at the goal line he's going to
fill up the stat sheet there's nothing
wrong with alvin kamara and you're
nitpicking when it comes to the top five
running backs barkley is six by the way
and it's not that far off so that's
where we're at with those let's get to a
bunch of your questions now as you've
been feeding them uh throughout the week
and even today on the br app uh cwi i'm
in a keeper league who do i keep
jonathan taylor we mentioned him from
the colts or and lose my third round
pick darren waller lose my fourth round
pick or cd lamb and lose my ninth round
pick so here's where i have these
players because i like to answer these
questions that help everybody out taylor
my rb 10 14th overall waller my tight
end 222nd overall landmine wide receiver
12 32nd overall so these are all great
values to me but if i'm talking about
the number 10 tight end and someone who
i would take in the first 14 picks if i
could get them in the third round i
probably want to go there if you want to
say but the value of cd lamb is
unbelievable i'm okay with that if you
say you know what i'm not worried about
running back i'll get one in the first
round and i'll move on from there that's
fine i'll go mix and match i do that
myself i would like to get a running
back in the first two rounds and then
i'm pretty much understanding that my
second running back spot is not going to
be a consistent role i'm going to deal
with injuries i'm going to deal with
changes in terms of roll so if you want
to say the value of cd lamb is too good
go ahead i don't have a problem with
that as i said though sometimes you take
these in a vacuum if i'm getting
jonathan taylor in the third round it's
a win to me none of those spots are bad
cw i got a pretty good team here let's
move on here uh jamming the ham with a
deep wide receiver pulls it smart
target running backs at the top of the
draft so yes here's my top 25 right now
my top 25 has nine wide receivers 14
running backs and two tight x
because
i think there are game changers at
running back like mccaffrey like barkley
like zeke like dalvin cook like alvin
kamara if i get one of those early it
may give me less of a reason to take a
running back in the second or the third
round i still think you're very much in
best player available mode um but i do
think the wide receiver group as a whole
from in terms of top tier to your talent
is deeper so i do like getting that
running back early injuries can happen
to anybody but the wide receiver group
is definitely deeper let's move on here
to nasty bird i am in a keeper league
between adams and cook who should i keep
as i said alvin cook rb2 second overall
devonte adams my wide receiver one
but seventh overall i'm going to go cook
there devonte adams look a lot of
question marks up until a couple weeks
ago because who was gonna play
quarterback for the green bay packers
well we know it's aaron rodgers would
cement and al davonte adams as my wide
receiver won i would go cook i have him
second overall i don't think you're
really gonna go wrong here but because
the wide receiver group is deeper uh i
will keep dalvin cook there let's move
on here uh keeler says eckler chubb and
zeke who do i take as i said i have zeke
at three uh third at running back third
overall i have echler at rb8 ninth
overall and i have chubb rb nine tenth
overall so it's zeke it's eckler it's
chubb uh eckler's still very important
to the charger offense you know where
are they at at running back do they have
anybody that they absolutely trust i
don't necessarily think so outside of
eckler but nick chubb getting that
extension from a really good team i mean
this is there's no secret anymore the
browns are one of the best teams in the
nfl let me repeat that the browns are
one of the best teams in the nfl and
nick chubb is a big part of that and i
know it's a deep team um but i will take
echo a little bit higher because i think
when you look at the weapons for the
chargers eckler is more important than
chubb once again it's nitpicking there
you're not in a bad spot with any of
these let's move on to coach k uh wants
to know should i take jk dobbins 19th
overall uh to me
dobbins a little high there rb16 28th
overall uh it's too early to know if he
will definitely be the lead i think he
will be you still have gus edwards there
you have lamar jackson as well who's
gonna run and yeah i know they have
sammy watkins this is a run first team
that's a little bit early to me because
i don't want to say with 100 confidence
that it's dobbins and don't worry about
anybody else they will use one two three
running backs the numbers were good last
year but we will always see others get
involved in that run first offense
that's just how they operate do they
need to pass more do they need to pass
more efficiency absolutely they do
but
because they have multiple players that
they can go to on the ground including
their quarterback i think taking dobbins
at 19 is just a bit too early let's move
on to another one here uh i think it's
uh soon am
should uh am i reaching too much for
picking daryl henderson with the first
pick for the third round half point 12
team league snake draft and we talked
about this earlier i admit rb20 40th
overall got a big bump with cam akers
out so
40th overall would put him where in the
fourth round i think that's a bit early
there i like the rams offense i think
you see when henderson has gotten the
chances he's been productive but can he
be the guy for an entire season that is
a fair question to ask when in doubt
sometimes you say is the guy in a good
team yes i think he is and stafford
makes them better but i do think it's a
bit too early to me he's probably more
of a middle of the fourth round pick uh
i think you're just going a little bit
early on someone like daryl henderson
i'm probably looking at some better
players available at wide receiver or
maybe even somebody like a darren waller
at the tight end position all right
let's get to another question here as
we're starting to wind down and this is
from zone gus edwards latavius murray or
jamal williams in a ppr league we've
brought all these names up so far here's
where i have them stacked right now and
i do see positives in all these players
gus edwards rb 37 84th overall latavius
murray rb 46 115 overall and i very well
could be moving them up as we learn more
about michael thomas and the jamal
williams rb 44 110 overall you see what
gus edwards did last year and i think
this annoyed some people now latavius
murray as we talked about earlier with
the saints having so much turnover
questions about michael thomas and you
know you're going to feed alvin kamara
both on the ground and through the air
murray's gonna be a solid option i think
murray is a very nice rb three to start
the season that could change i'll give
you a little uh early advice here
latavius murray could get off to a good
start without michael thomas out there
and then michael thomas gets back maybe
latavius murray's uh value drops a
little bit maybe he's a sell high
candidate if he gets off to a good start
and then you got tamal williams uh now
with their with deandre swift in detroit
on the team that wants to run the
football solid when given the
opportunity but not great uh eileen
edwards there probably for the majority
of the season another one here uh from
wham imna keepers league i'm debating
between waller and giving up my fifth
round or henderson and giving up my 11th
round waller as i said tight end number
two 22nd overall what a year he had last
year for the las vegas raiders henderson
rb 20 40th overall so the values here
let's just separate these two the values
for both players is outstanding but when
i'm talking about a player who's 40th
overall who is going to give me a
significant advantage at the tight end
position where there's maybe five or six
big time tight ends and questions about
others
i think i just take wall there in the
fifth i think i go best player available
but both values are absolutely fantastic
eileen waller with that one uh let's try
to sneak another couple of ones in here
as we're winding down aaron jones or jt
i assume you mean jonathan taylor
rogers back adam's back i still like
aaron jones there yes i'm a little bit
worried about dylan i understand that
but uh i i like the situation in green
bay i have jones a few spots higher than
jonathan taylor uh brad here we'll get
to another one ten team standard scoring
keeper league do i keep hopkins
and aaron jones if you can keep them
both yes um if i'm ranking them i
probably go hopkins a bit higher but
both spots are good and if you're
starting your 10 teamer off with two
bona fide rb1 wide receiver ones in
their respective categories you're in a
good spot vex let's get to you higher
upside
keenan allen or scary terry mclaren and
who would you rather have in a full ppr
this is alan and the answer is alan for
both of these
you pretty much lock allen down for 100
catches i hope ryan fitzpatrick is the
starting quarterback for the team in
washington for the majority of the
season because he is fantasy friendly
but i trust keane and alan moore so
we're gonna go keenan allen on that one
uh let's see next one here danny are you
buying zach wilson as a late round
quarterback option he's gonna have some
weapons
yeah i look
when you look at a spot like that you
say late round
but am i going to need that roster spot
you know in a best ball league sure
you know throw him in there and maybe he
ends up in your starting lineup in a
best ball because it's automatically
formatted anyway
but if i'm taking a late round
quarterback and i i'm going to stream my
quarterbacks if i have somebody i trust
i'm going to go with that guy as long as
i can and when i need to pick somebody
else up i will so i think it matters on
what kind of league you're playing but
in the best ball sure throw them in
there and uh maybe get a couple weeks
out of them let's get another one in
here well jonathan taylor from uh pdo
boyle be affected negatively to start
the season by marlon mack in the injury
to nelson and wins yeah you got o-line
issues there you got wentz being a
question mark although it seems to be
more positive news on both of those
players as of late mack is probably a
thorn in your side as as we dealt with
jonathan taylor but early on yeah i
think there are some question marks with
jonathan taylor and might i add
if he is someone who struggles early he
might be a buy low candidate all right
uh let's see if we can get a couple
other ones in here ntn or mike dave week
one questions here let me make this very
clear we're not even in september yet
you are not setting any lineups
in week one
before it's even september you're not
even setting those lineups until two
days before that thursday night game
between dallas and tampa bay take your
time a lot's gonna happen between now
and week number one and guess what i'll
be with you here for the next three
thursdays 1 p.m eastern on the brf
covering fantasy football for br
gridiron make sure you keep getting your
questions in you can find me on twitter
and instagram at the mat camp fire
questions there but get them in the app
i'll answer plenty more next week we'll
have more rankings injuries and all the
news to talk about coming off the first
full week of pre-season action i'm matt
camp and i'll see you next thursday
right here
at 1pm eastern on your fantasy fire
drill
[Music]
[Applause]
you